President Trump says the partial
government shutdown could last months or
more than a year although he hopes
negotiations will be fruitful in coming
days but the president also says he's
considering declaring a national
emergency in order to build his border
wall with or without Congress the
statements come on the day the stock
market surged on higher than expected
jobs numbers for December and the
Federal Reserve chair saying he will be
patient with interest rate hikes we have
Fox team coverage tonight doesn't Kelly
ways on Capitol Hill where Democrats are
firmly entrenched against the
president's border wall correspondent
Kevin cork those starts us off tonight
from the White House where the president
seems equally committed to his position
good evening Kevin evening Brett asked
if he would consider those emergency
powers to grant himself the authority to
somehow fund the wall without
congressional approval the president
said yes he'd come he thought about it
and yes he would do it if it came to
that just the very latest twist in the
ongoing debate about funding the wall
and ending the partial government
shutdown we can use them absolutely we
can call a national emergency because of
the security of our country absolutely
no we can do it I haven't done it I may
do it I may do it but we could call a
national emergency and build it very
quickly
president Trump today on the heels of a
two-hour meeting with Democrats here at
the White House we just completed a
lengthy and sometimes contentious
conversation with the president we had a
very very productive meeting two
viewpoints of a very important meeting
with a singular purpose to end the
partial government shutdown I'm not
saying it was an easy meeting or even a
kind meeting or a nice meeting but in
the end I think we've come a long way
we're gonna be working very hard over
the weekend it was a second such
gathering this week of leaders from both
parties in the Situation Room here at
the White House while neither side would
share specifics about the conversations
the consensus was there's more work to
be done the southern border is a
dangerous horrible disaster we've done a
great job but you can't really do the
kind of job we have to do unless you
have a major powerful barrier
and that's what we're going to have to
have our aim will be to find a solution
not just simply to end the government
shutdown to provide funding to end the
crisis at our southern border to achieve
real border security and to build a wall
on our southern border the wall the
pillar the president's promise to defend
the border and an absolute non-starter
for Democrats who vowed to stand pat
until the president reopened the
government we have a disagreement on the
refusal of the president to open up the
government but with the impasse now at
14 days and Counting the prospects of a
quick solution seem considerably murky
at best it's very hard to see how
progress will be made unless they open
up the government and I think I can
speak for Republicans in the House and
Republicans in the Senate they feel very
strongly about having a safe country
having a border that makes sense without
borders I've said it many times we don't
have a country I hope it doesn't go on
even beyond a few more days and the
meetings Brett continued tomorrow both
at 11:00 and 1:00 o'clock including the
vice president Mike Pence as they try to
end the impasse another very quick note
senior administration officials Brett
are set to receive $10,000 annual raises
beginning tomorrow and while today the
vice president said he would turn down
his raise the president said he would
consider asking other senior officials
to follow suit right Kevin you know the
president threatened to declare a
national emergency to build the wall so
can he actually do that
well the listen most people say no he
can't do that Brett but I think a better
answer is it depends because while
legally he cannot without congressional
approval say take money from one pot in
the federal budget and move it to
another to build a wall other legal
scholars always warn us about the broad
nature of the President's powers under a
national emergency either way if he
attempted to do so it is a certainty
that he would face a legal challenge
from lawmakers and others
the North Lawn Kevin thank you